The Walking Dead Season 9 has thrown
some pretty big moments our audiences
there's been a six-year time jump the
departure of a major character and the
introduction of a new set of villains
the season has just dropped its
midseason finale and throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
you need to know from episode 8
evolution there will of course be heavy
spoilers so if you haven't seen the
episode yet then I highly suggest that
you turn off now for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to last week we saw Daryl decide to
return to what's left of civilization
and agreed to look after Carol son Henry
at the end of the episode Daryl was
asked to help look for Eugene who had
been separated from Rosita after they
were set on by heard of Walker's that
exhibited unusual behavior this new
chatty bunch of walkers becomes the main
focus of this week's episode and we
learn a lot more about how they are able
to communicate and what's actually going
on with their golem impression first
Carol and Daryl become Legolas and
Aragorn and now the walkers are talking
like like junior are talking talking
though works a bit better when I don't
have to explain it anyway
Daryl and Co eventually find Eugene who
seems hysterical and paranoid that the
walkers are after him specifically this
story is corroborated by Rosita who
wakes up alive and well after being
treated by the survivors and this
episode finally confirms that we are
indeed dealing with the whisperers once
and for all for those who don't know the
whisperers are your worst nightmare and
make negan look like Gabriel they are a
culmination of the scavengers and the
wolves and where the Dead face is over
their own in order to camouflage amongst
them perfectly eagle-eyed viewers will
remember Morgan mentioning in season 3
that had seen people wearing the Dead's
faces and this was the first tease of
them that has finally come to fruition
in this episode the whisperers
communicate by whispering to one another
and this avoids the dead that surround
them noticing their presence it's the
perfect disguise that allows them to
hide in plain sight and travel the land
with a caravan of the undead behind them
basically they're complete Psychopaths
difficult to reason with and also stink
probably and imagine we're in your
Auntie Sandra's face in your head all
day is gonna make you smell like urine
and were this original and hey that's
enough to make anyone grumpy in the
midseason finale Aaron Jesus and Eugene
fittingly become trapped in the cemetery
and have to battle their way out the
majority of the group make it except for
Jesus who stays behind defend the
walkers off when one Dodge is a strike
and stabs him back during the words you
are not way you are not where you've
stuck on due to us you are not where you
belong
we know that the whisperers are here in
full force this is taken from the
Walking Dead issue 134 when Jesus here's
one of the whisperers speak and then
questions what they are that's when one
of them says back we are the whisperers
and you are not where you belong that
was pretty good however in the pooka
cheese has manages to kill them whereas
the television counterpart is not so
lucky it's safe to say Jesus like his
name will rise again but this time you
probably be out for blood and not the
second coming of Christ we leave our
group surrounded by the herd with very
little hope of getting out but hopefully
the character's death will leave Mackey
to return to hilltop once more but we'll
just have to see
looking at the trailers for next season
it appears that the group escaped the
cemetery and with the prisoner elsewhere
Gabriel forgets a lot negan cell and the
latter character escapes this entire
event is kind of overshadowed by the
sheer zombie horror on screen though I
imagine that the Belen quickly returns
when he sees the new threat that has
emerged so what are your thoughts on the
mid-season finale of season 9 are you
enjoying the new features of The Walking
Dead and what you hope to see when the
show returns comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of last week's episode
Stradivarius which will be linked at the
end of this one this is a channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]